speaking of what's going on in politics
and you know uh
elaborating on this segment we have an
article here from the blaze
[Laughter]
will joe biden and ibram kendy save
novak's blacks from jab crow attacks
donald squires so but but this is the
general idea i guess is around like vote
uh around voter id being racist but now
they're demanding ids in new york do you
want to just let it tell us what the
article's about which sure sure so
it um articles about a couple things one
i started off thinking about ibram kendy
and his assertion that any policy that
produces
um disparate or or inequitable
outcomes is in and of itself racial
racist so if there's a particular public
policy
and it impacts black people black and
hispanic people more than whites and
asians then that policy is racist but
then i also thought about how joe biden
at one point called a proposed law in
georgia that would require among other
things would require
and a valid id to vote by mail
he said that that law made
jim crow look like jim eagle and i said
oh okay so i could see these two
partnering up and saying that vaccine
passports
particularly the new york city policy
pushed by de blasio
which
um which would have a a disproportionate
effect on black communities because only
it's less than 40 percent of black new
yorkers are actually vaccinated
i expect ibram kenny and joe biden to
both say that jab crow
is totally unacceptable in america in
2020
and that
this policy that is going to produce
disparate you know racial outcomes is in
and of itself racist right and ibra
candy if he did that
that would mean he would be calling some
of his biggest supporters on the left
racist the people were pushing this
um and i'm just curious as to whether or
not these two will stand on principle
um or whether they will sacrifice
you know their sacred cow of racial
equity come on on the altar of political
pragmatism i'm not gonna come out and
say anything no no
i love the jab crow though that was that
was that was brilliant yeah you know but
joe biden might but he might not um
not legitimately what might happen is
because of the backlash he might then be
like oh yeah well you know we're always
saying id you can't do that so in this
instance if there's enough outrage
then he might just find it as an excuse
to be like oh here's why i post it's not
about vaccines you know he can save face
in that regard right and say oh i am for
people getting the vaccine and you know
wanting to have that security but you
know we can't have ids to get in
buildings yeah but see but but i think
part of the issue and this is why you
see the media pushing
the narrative of the unvaccinated being
white evangelical trump voters because
they don't want to tell the truth which
is nationally again
black americans have lower rates of
vaccination than other groups but if
they can make uh vaccination into a
a white evangelical conservative issue
then it's a lot more palatable for
people
to say we want to enforce vaccination
with vaccine passports this is crazy too
because for a long time they were saying
they wanted to roll out the vaccine
program based on race yeah they wanted
minorities to get access first because
they were under vaccinated and people
were like that that to me was kind of a
so i'm i'm
i'm very much
philosophically behind universal
healthcare i just don't know if we can
possibly do it right that's the big
challenge but the idea that somebody
that we could we could pay lower rates
save trillions of dollars because
everybody's pitching into a functioning
system it sounds brilliant right until
you learn that what does the government
do once they have the ability to
regulate health they do it based on race
no i i i don't think that's a good idea
to give the power to the government when
they do things like that
so so one of the things i talk about an
article right
is
you know when i get serious and i get
past the sort of tongue and cheek stuff
about jab crow
is
this is actually a perfect example
of why ibram candy's philosophy of
anti-racism and racial equity will never
work because what you've seen in this
rollout is to your point whether people
agree with it or not an emphasis on
um
providing vaccine access to low-income
black and hispanic communities
all out public awareness campaigns to
get those communities vaccinated
making the vaccine free to everyone
putting you know vaccine centers right
in the heart of communities in the
neighborhood i was living in dc there
was one by the grocery store that their
cvs is all over the place and you still
see
um different rates by group in terms of
vaccination so one of the things i talk
about is a principle i call it squash
principle because that's what people do
they name stuff after themselves
and um
it's fairly simple
the premise is this
that government control has a direct
relationship with
the perceived success of any policy but
individual agency has an inverse
relationship because the government is
good at certain things the government
can say we want to build new rec centers
in all the low-income neighborhoods they
have the resources they have the
political will
they can do that what they can't do is
guarantee that we're going to
reduce diabetes and hypertension by 75
because that has to do with how people
eat how they exercise
and and how they rest now they can do
things on the periphery but ultimately
the more policy requires individual
agency um the less successful it's going
to be from the government's perspective
well so so
you still have the black community
less vaccinated than other racial
demographics even with all of these
programs correct
so there's no policy solution is there
it's a it's cultural or or what is it
part of it and i know people who work in
government don't like to hear this but
sometimes people don't want the things
that you want to give them for one
reason or the other because as adults as
rational adults people make decisions
they may say the risk of me
getting covert in a serious bout of
covid and you know the worst type of
symptoms is not worth me
you know taking this particular vaccine
now we may agree with the decision or
not but it's their decision but that's
something that the left has a hard time
with right they think if we think it's
social good everybody else should and
instead of trying to
persuade
um be honest about facts answer
questions honestly
you know
take a nuanced approach
they say you know what we're done with
the error of persuasion we're into
coercion and force and that's what the
vaccine passport is that was a good
point you made about how if they feel as
a social good everyone else must as well
it's bigger than that it's that they
believe their world view is the same
within every single person yes and so to
them here's here's one i have to bring
up which plays your point as well
if i was given a free place to live i'd
take it therefore all homeless people
need only be given a free place to live
and homelessness is solved right except
i've worked with homeless shelters and
you know you know you know what you get
most of the time when you go to homeless
person offer my shelter so no
sir we have a vehicle waiting for you
right here and they're like i got stuff
i got friends right this is where i live
right i don't know you i don't want to
be anywhere near you i don't care about
your house you know people who are used
to living outside are not
you know i guess you've got young people
they're naive
and they must genuinely believe like
well who wouldn't want to have a bed to
sleep in some people like their sleeping
bag under a bridge i'm not exaggerating
i'm not saying it's a good thing but
they that's what they know that's what
they're used to and they feel safe there
and so the left just assumes every
homeless person is actually just a down
on their luck you know out of work laid
off guy holding a sign saying we'll work
for food lack of affordable housing
right
and so the solutions they often offer up
are hey how about we put vaccination
centers in all the black neighborhoods
that way they'll get vaccinated and then
they don't because they're not actually
addressing the community's needs or or
desires in any meaningful way other than
just some bland policy position that
doesn't solve the problem yeah it's not
it's not like it's a black person white
person thing they horribly guffed this
whole covet experience for every human
like i don't think it's a racial has
anything with race about how we
are questioning i do think that like
look it's a critical thought maybe maybe
that's is that inherent in the black
community critical thought like critical
race theory it's a joke i don't know
we're genetically different but like
critical but like no no not that
different i i think race plays an
obvious role in um
how communities form we see it with
immigration
people choose to move to areas where
like you know you end up with a
chinatown you end up with a little italy
yeah maybe maybe it's not maybe race
isn't not the right word maybe ethnicity
yeah we're the same race or its culture
is probably better like familiarity
probably is a better way to put it yeah
so so i know in the beginning a lot of
the talk around quote-unquote vaccine
hesitancy was around
you know you saw articles on the
tuskegee experiment and history of black
communities with the healthcare
professions i'm not saying some of that
doesn't exist right
but again people make decisions for all
types of reasons i don't think every
black person who doesn't want to get the
shot is doing it because of the tuskegee
i don't think they're doing it because
they don't have access to it some people
just say i don't want it but for
whatever reason
that's an answer that some of our
elected officials just
cannot stomach they won't allow it no
these people they must be vaccinated and
that's why you see
um actually this morning this was going
around on twitter ari melber was quoting
the notorious b.i.g
um a song from way back he was talking
about you know what's beef and talking
about you end up in the icu and ari
melbourne was trying to link that to not
getting the shot because if you don't
get the shot and you get covered you may
end up in icu and a lot of people you
know who i follow on social media were
like what is this guy talking about i
mean it was bad
you know to appropriate biggie's lyrics
to push you know your particular agenda
is not something that is going to
convince anyone so
again i can't answer for why everyone
chooses not to do it but to your point
people should consult their medical
professionals and they can they should
make a decision that makes sense for
them i agree with you i don't think most
of the problems that we talk about as
racial problems are racial problems
i come again i come with a with a
biblical worldview i believe there's
there's one race
many ethnicities many nationalities um
but
in our country we that's the way we tend
to think about things and i think people
like ibrahim candy have made that
even worse and that's why
it was a shot at him sort of
tongue-in-cheek i just want to see if
he's going to stand on his own
principles
my guess is that he won't yeah i'd agree
with that i'd make a gentleman's bet
it's an industry to protect yeah yeah
yeah grievous industrial complex yeah
that's good did you come up with that
one i like that one other people say it
but i was saying it before they saw that
that's right that's a good one too
grievous industrial complex man that's
that's big yeah we have critical race
applied principles well now that's
pretty good oh yeah absolutely have you
heard that one critical race applied
principles i have not that's actually
one of our super chatters said that so
so you know in schools it's critical
race practice yeah when they put the
theory in practice practice and i'm like
we need an a in there
and someone said critical race applied
principles yes and we are like yeah
that's good thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you